a friend of mine died and he was a
really good guy really dear director
some people know some of his work maybe
you don't know the extent of all his
work gentleman's name was David Ellis
David Ellis was a to put it quickly
David Ellis was the director of snakes
on a plane now that's just one thing
that he did David Ellis led this
amazingly [ __ ] long life he was from
Malibu
the dude became a champion surfer like
he's still cannot work as he passed but
he still was considered up until [ __ ]
a few days ago one of the best surfers
on the planet like one of the top 50 or
whatever David kind of stumbled into
stunt work on movies I believe one of
the first one he did was he doubled Kurt
Russell or something like the World's
Strongest Man or the race was one of the
Disney flicks so he started as a
stuntman and worked in stunts for years
and years and what happens is if you're
around movies long enough and you do
stunts and stuff eventually they ask you
to do second unit second unit is when
you have a movie that you're making
that's real big and [ __ ] you need stunts
to be done but you want to concentrate
on the key performance as the actors you
have a second unit some movies have
third and fourth units depending how big
they are and stuff so like at one point
when I was thinking about doing that
Green Hornet movie I was just like I
can't direct action I don't know how to
make cars and move and [ __ ] like that
and they were like do you think Bryan
Singer directed all of x-men 2 and I was
like of course they're like no he
directs the performances and a lot of
the big action sequences second unit
comes in and [ __ ] I was like oh you're
kidding me so on cop-out man I needed a
second unit director because there was
some driving stuff some action stuff and
they said we're gonna give you David
Ellis David has been a second unit
director and the first year director he
became a director not just a stunt and
[ __ ] like that became so good at it they
were like give him a whole movie so he
started making flicks and directing
flicks like I went from like a surfer to
being a stunt man to being a second unit
director which is like I'm no longer
doing the stunts but I'm figuring him
out and shooting the stunts and the
director of the movie is like trust you
enough to be like you take these five
pages and go shoot the [ __ ] out of it
and stuff and those cats don't get
credit in the up-front they're usually
bird in the bag on their second unit
director of stuff he came in and worked
for us and he was like he's a wizard at
putting together moving shots and he was
so sweet one of the nicest people in the
world I ever met his he
Megan my sister he was like I want to
get Kevin a thank you gift for giving me
a job which I'm like I didn't really
give you a job dude like you're a
working directorship he's always happy
to be working and they like try new
things so he's like I want to get him a
gift what should I get him Megan's like
smokes weed he goes perfect and then and
we never thought anything of it two days
later he sent me like a box that had
syrup in and [ __ ] I was like that's nice
he sent me Sierra Megan's like look
under the bottom and I looked I was like
he sent me weed now that's cute story
this is my favorite David Ellis story
this is what he told me and he was a
beautiful light in this world and it's
sad that he passed and particularly he
was young 61 he told me a story as a
stuntman this is cutest [ __ ] he's a
stuntman and he was in Louisiana New
Orleans they were shooting the stuff so
he's in a car he's trying to talk
someone in a cell phone so he's like
[ __ ] pulled over into what was a
cul-de-sac so he pulls over he's on the
phone going uh-huh yeah we're gonna
shoot this thing but like I need this
much more blah blah blah car rolls up to
him like behind him and then a car rolls
up to the side of them and he's about to
get carjacked he could totally recognize
it the dudes are stepping out of the car
with guns like this so David I guess the
car pulled in front of him cuz this is
what happens he did what's known as in
the stunt business as a j-turn out of
nowhere he's a trained stunt driver so
these dudes are blocking him and he
pulls they pull out guns start walking
toward him and David goes [ __ ] it ah and
the car does this [ __ ] backwards
speeding J does a skid around and faces
them like Batman and I said what
happened he's gone they sped away
I love that man so he was a really sweet
guy and a lot of people like kick
second-unit directors of [ __ ] cuz like
oh you're not a big [ __ ] director but
he did direct a movie that we all know
and most of us kind of love which is
snakes on a plane as well as final
destination - and he also did the final
destination very talented man very
beloved in this town in business and I
met him and again not just like he was a
good guy in the movie business one of
the most fascinating people I ever met I
was heartbroken to hear that he died
where was it South Africa he was
prepping the show he's gonna direct
another film he's gonna be with Sam
Jackson again directing other Sam
Jackson movie he did the action
sequences as you mentioned for
Waterworld Matrix Reloaded and Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone so
this guy was the real deal
segi new director on Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's come on he was a huge
cauldron a win he will be missed David I
love you thank you for your help man
thank you for your friendship and lastly
for those of you who are listening from
out of state of California and maybe you
hear from out of state you may not
recognize the name but locals here in
California will recognize the name of
Huell Howser who passed out
[Applause]
[Music]
Huell Howser was the host of maybe the
worst show on television
[Laughter]
[ __ ] true and look no disrespect to
the man he was beloved but his show was
a turd it was called California's gold
and Huell every week for the PBS local
PBS station here in California would go
out with a handheld mic and a cameraman
and would spend an hour talking to
somebody who likes sold bras [ __ ] you
not that was an entire episode but give
him props because he was the originator
almost of the sentiment interested is
interesting right because the people he
were talking to it could be something
like I make paper bags and [ __ ] Huell
was just like
isn't that amazing that's amazing
you sit here all day and you manufacture
paper bags Wow
and each of these bags there will hold
something won't they
some of them will go to supermarkets
other ones that go to clothing stores
you don't know where these bags will end
up some of them will be put on
children's heads and they'll cut out eye
holes you can draw on them it's amazing
this [ __ ] would go on for an hour and
a PBS and our show is [ __ ] 60 minutes
by the way
I kid but you'll had a way of made
drawing you in he would he would talk to
the world's whistling champ and while
you whistle all kinds of music not just
songs we think of as whistle songs like
The Andy Griffith themes no you whistle
somewhere over the rainbow that is
amazing I would have loved to be
interviewed by him cuz he would have
made you feel like a [ __ ] smartest
person you invented the lame bird
sprinkler head anyway this show is on
the air for 20 years only on PBS could
have show like this last for 20 years he
had California's called he had video log
he had visiting with Yul Hauser he was
never out of work and he became sort of
a local icon just for the sheer fact
that everyone knew Huell Howser he
passed away this week after just
retiring 67 years old his home in Palm
Springs California for those of you who
aren't familiar with eul's work I did
bring in a little taste a little video
of his work this is Huell Howser in his
prime prime Ewell Howser moment where he
is on a small avocado farm here in the
state of California
some of you may be familiar with this
piece of work
and he's talking to the avocado farmers
and as you can imagine he runs out of
things to talk about about 18 minutes
into the hour-long segment Wow look at
those trees they're covered with
avocados and he realizes that one of the
farmers dogs is eating the avocados on
the ground
Huell lost his [ __ ] because he had never
seen a dog eating avocado before I
present for your viewing pleasure Huell
Howser and the avocado eating dog your
dog is eating an avocado yeah that dog
eats avocado all our dogs eat avocados
if your Nava kado farm or your dogs like
some - I've never seen a dog eat avocado
in your kitchen that dog ate every smack
of that avocado how do you have a
healthy dog I got a very healthy dog you
want to see how to make a dog happy
now that's an avocado eating dog yeah
sure is you'll that sure [ __ ] is a
avocado eating dog be fair dude he's
more interesting fascinating and [ __ ]
compelling than the Kardashians yeah
well yeah like saying I'm a better track
and field runner than Stephen Hawking
hardly a comparison sir big bucket of
wind big bucket of fuel bucket of women
that is amazing
I am dead I won't be living anymore Wow
my body sure is still and yet I'm still
interested in things at this point in
heaven God's like send him to hell
that's right
look at those pearly gates are all those
people coming through to go to heaven
Wow look at all these clouds those
Angels have halos that cherubs eating an
avocado that sure is an avocado eatin
cherub
[Music]
you